first of all i just want to say
i'm so happy to talk to you i'm a huge
fan of your work
and i'm so thankful to netflix for
making your movie
thank you um i will say that it does
feel like netflix is actually
like a really good place for you to
partner with
in in making a movie like this because
um
it just feels like a really good fit can
you sort of talk about the relationship
with them and
how you ended up working with them yeah
well i found ian reed's book and um
i was interested in trying to adapt it
as a as a movie and
um i spoke to my producer anthony
bregman
who has a deal with netflix and he said
um i think we can get this made so
um i went to netflix with anthony and we
chatted and they agreed to it
even before the script was written just
based on the book and i
i guess our conversation um and
they you know they let me make the movie
i wanted to make they left
they left us alone to make it and so it
was great
i've spoken to a lot of filmmakers
who've worked with them and they all say
that the notes that they're given by
netflix
are usually pretty good and um you know
that they're really filmmaker friendly
did you have that similar experience
absolutely yes definitely did you
um did they how much do you
listen to notes if you will for when the
studio gives it and how much is it sort
of do you know what i mean like do you
ever get really good notes from people
and
you're like wow that's really good i
need to incorporate that
sure yeah i mean it certainly happens it
doesn't always happen and but i mean
it's a case-by-case thing and
you know you i you have to be open to
the things that
the people you're working with say so of
course i tried to be
i'm going to try to ask you two
questions you've not been asked yet
today
i hope um uh tv right now is better than
it's ever been
um is there a tv series out there that
you'd be willing to guest
right and direct
um pen 15.
okay i really like that show
i just rewatched the first episode last
night so it's on my mind but
those those women are astounding
i just can't believe that they're adults
it's you know do you know the show
i'm i'm imagining your version of this
you know i don't think i'd be right for
it
and no but i mean i just i just i i
really respect what they're doing and
how well they do it
so yeah that's the first thing that came
to mind
sure um and my other question for you is
what movie do you think you've seen the
most
i don't know that's a good question um
because i think it go i probably seen
like um
i don't know like a david lynch thing
maybe um
but i'm not sure which one and i mean
i don't think i've watched movies over
and over and over again
i mean i've seen several david lynch
movies several times i'm
i've seen naked um mike lee's movie
with david doulas several times um
i can't think i can't think of any
others i mean i i know there are but you
know they don't come to mind
sure one of the things that i really
enjoy about your work
um and especially this film is that i
like martin
i like bard and fink a lot too i haven't
seen in a long time but
that's a that's a movie that um i think
is really funny
i think the coen brothers are going to
land on their feet yeah
um one of the things though that i love
about your work and especially this film
is that it leaves a lot
uh open to the viewer to in tor and to
interpret
you know what they want to see in it
you're not dictating um
an exact sort of thing if you will um
can you talk about sort of writing that
and maybe
what it's like in the editing room
making sure you find the right bit that
you want to sort of
put out there well i mean i think a lot
of it is in the script
and trying to make the script exist on
different levels
not just one level and not just be like
this sort of plot driven thing but to
have
different elements and different ideas
that are that are kind of like built
into it
and then you use that as the basis for
understanding what you need to do
you know in production and in
post-production um
you know there are ways to sort of like
um build on that with sound design
and and use it you know use the the
photography to kind of
get certain ideas across and you just
have those in your head while you're
working
sure um i'm fascinated by the editing
process because ultimately that's the
final rewrite
um when you got in the editing room with
all your footage maybe did anything
surprise you
were you nervous were you excited so
many directors i've spoken to say that
sometimes when they start watching the
footage they just question life
i think you know the the very early cuts
are
painful they can be painful um
and you just sort of like i think you if
you've done it a few times and
i've had the good fortune of working
with directors um in post-production
before i started directing myself so
i've seen those
those those versions those very bad
versions of things and
so i'm less worried about it than um
than i might be
um but yeah i mean
you just you know it's it is as you said
it's it's writing and you make
choices and you move some things around
and you take some things out and
you live with it and then you look at it
again and you give yourself some space
from it and you look at it again and
you watch it with an audience and see
how they react and get a sense of
you know something that's not understood
or or
if their attention is lagging you know
and then you make changes
it's um it's a it's like any
i think it's like any writing process
it's a constant sort of thing of going
back and
reviewing and rethinking um who do you
actually trust for honest feedback
in that in that regard i mean i trust i
trust rob frazen
my editor i work i worked with him on
this and um on synecdoche and on the
pilot
i did for fx um so we have a history
together and i think we understand each
other and i think he knows
uh what i what i want and and he has his
own
ideas and they're generally kind of
sympatico and
yeah trust him sure how can i ask how
long was your first cut compared to the
finished film
i don't remember i mean the assembly
before i even got there was i don't
remember how long it was it wasn't
it wasn't extraordinarily long like well
maybe we've lost an hour
of the movie maybe it was like three
hours i that that sounds right to me but
i'm
kind of guessing i'm not no i'm not i'm
not sure i'm remembering or guessing but
i think it was about three hours
now with you like when you're talking
about a cut like that that's not a cut
that you want people to see that's like
all the footage
like like everything in one line it's
the scenes assembled
as they're written you know as the
script
dictates and then you kind of make
decisions and you know move things
around take things out
trade out takes you know um
yeah it's it's not something you want
people to see it's that's what you're
working with
what was the last scene you cut out of
the film uh before you picture locked
and why did you cut it i'm not sure we
cut any scenes out of this film i i mean
i uh huh it's a good question i
um i'm throwing you curveballs today
yeah yeah yeah um i i we certainly
tightened things and and
took out segments of scenes but there
aren't
that many scenes in the movie um really
and i don't think we've removed any of
them um
that that's not that yeah i feel pretty
confident about that
uh there's nothing there's no entire
scene that's missing from the movie
sure uh i really loved the uh tulsi town
commercial
there's a lot of stuff in the third act
that i really loved but i loved the way
the animation and
could you sort of talk about designing
that sequence so originally it was a
dairy queen
um in the book it's a dairy queen and
and in um
my script it was a dairy queen but derek
queen would not let us use their name
um because uh the the girl has open
sores on her arm the
girl who's making the the drinks
um so i made up a company called tulsi
town
and um but but before i did that
i found a very old dairy queen
commercial um online
and it was really creepy and um
it was in black and white and i i i
loved it and i was planning on
using it in the movie but since we
didn't have dairy queen i couldn't so um
you know i worked with the um with the
people that i worked with on anomalisa
who um um rosa tran and duke johnson
who um got animators to come in and
and you know we looked at
this particular commercial and and it
was i mean it wasn't copy but the tone
of it and the look of it was kind of
like try
we tried to sort of get something
equivalent to it um
and my um um the woman who sang little
person
in synecdoche um
and and the other songs in snake cookie
as well diana's story she um
she sang the jingle and then we animated
it
her singing to the we animated it to her
singing
and uh so that's how that happened
sure it's great um i loved your i'm
going to butcher the name
amilisa uh the stop motion movie i
i love it um and i love the way that you
they you brought
your voice to stop mo like it's just
great
um have you given any more thought to
doing something else in stop motion or
was that just
such a daunting process you're like no
no i mean uh
you know i've talked about it with the
people i worked with on that
uh a fair amount around the time that we
made it
but um you know we weren't really able
to kind of make anything happen because
the movie didn't make any money
um and so
it's you know you're not going to get
the financing to
get do another project so but yeah i
love stop motion and
in fact i made it a big part of my novel
um
after having the experience of of um
working on anomalisa
if you could get the financing today for
any project that you have written
something you've always wanted to make
uh what would you make and why
well i mean developing this thing for
hbo which is
which is a limited series about a about
a virus
that causes stupidity and it's based on
a screenplay i wrote which is based on a
novel
called iq 83 and um i'm actually
developing it for them so it's possible
that it's going to happen i don't know
that it's going to happen
but i'm very interested in because of
the circumstances in which we live i'm
very interested in
exploring the notion of that and um
and treating it as a you know kind of a
metaphor
i'm i'm very curious can you share um
one of the things that a lot of
your fam myself and fans of yours were
very excited about was you partnering
possibly with del toro on slaughterhouse
five uh whatever ended up happening with
that
um nothing i mean we he and i had a
conversation and
it didn't it didn't really it didn't
amount to anything it didn't it didn't
happen
so um which is kind of just as well
because i'm not
really all that interested in um
adapting
a novel like that i mean it's it's a
great novel
i love it uh i think it's very difficult
i think it's a very difficult novel to
adapt into i mean i know it's been done
and i don't
really particularly like the version
that exists um
but i'm not entirely sure how to make a
better version well i also wonder
recently i've i've started just coming
around to the fact that a lot of
material is better suited for a six or
eight episode limited series
than a two hour i mean and and that's
that's true i agree with that i i think
that
it's possible that slaughterhouse five
would work better in that form
and um i hadn't thought about it but
yeah you might be right
i wanted to know what was it like
shooting those driving scenes in the
movie because i know you had
a limited amount of time to shoot the
film but there's so much that takes
place in the car
um sort of talk about filming those
sequences and the challenges of
you know so much dialogue and so much in
the car
yeah and we shot it um in a warehouse
and in front of green screens and so
it wasn't as miserable an experience as
it might have been if we if we had to
shoot it
in the actual snow um but
yeah um i was worried about it and
wukash my my dp was worried about
keeping it
interesting and um you know we had
limited angles we
we could use because it was a car and um
but i think it ended up being because
jesse and jesse were so compelling
uh in their performances that i i i
never found it
once i saw it on film i never found it a
worry i
i thought these scenes are really good
and i'm i'm
i'm really happy to watch them so um
so yeah that's that's it sure the uh
how did you end up being on set in terms
of did you do you find yourself doing a
lot of takes
are you do you find that like you enjoy
two or three takes
what are you like on set uh when you're
when you're actually filming
i mean again i think the actors are so
good in this that i i didn't really
feel the need to do a lot of takes i
also just didn't have the time
to to do a lot of takes because we we
had very limited time
um shooting days and um
but yeah i would say i i always say it
was probably
around two to three takes for each shot
for each shot okay so
you you were really zooming through yeah
we had to
but also i was satisfied so there was no
reason to push that
yeah they seem to be talented you know
jesse and jesse
jesse and jesse and david and tony are
all very talented
they're okay um i think it's right my
last question for you
you're you're going in and you uh
obviously you have limited time
limited money to make your movie what
were you most nervous about being able
to pull off
with the time and money that you had to
make your film
hmm i think i was probably most nervous
about the dining room scene
um just because again we were in very
enclosed space we had very limited
opportunity to sort of
move the camera um and it was
a very static scene you know with people
sitting around a table
um and but it was more complicated than
the
um than the car stuff because there were
four of them
so i was nervous about getting all the
coverage that i needed
and making it compelling um but i mean
all in all i don't think there was much
that was um
too complicated to shoot for us
um we had a crane shot which you know
took some time
for us to set up other than that it was
pretty straightforward
on that note i need to go sarah
congratulations on the movie is
a real pleasure to talk to you today
thank you so much thank you
bye-bye